uh on the friday show i am going to be
answering an audience question
about which republicans are likely to
get out of the way if donald trump runs
in 2024
versus which republicans are likely to
run against trump in 2024 uh
the the the list of the latter is
probably relatively short i think mitt
romney would be
someone who's on the list even though i
don't think romney plans to run
romney is the type of guy who if he
wants to run in 2024
he'll run against trump in the
republican primary he won't step down
or step back or stand by because donald
trump may choose to run
the new report from axios is that chris
christie's
friends believe he is gearing up for a
2024 run
axios writing that former new jersey
governor chris christie
is seriously considering running for
president in 2024
three people familiar with his thinking
tell axios
while christy isn't saying anything
publicly besides telling
radio host hugh hewitt that he's not
ruling it out people close to christy
have a sense of the rationale
and outlines of a candidacy the big
picture is that absent
a run by trump the field would be wide
open
christie ran in 2016 didn't go well
he told friends he'd be the only person
in 2024
with executive experience who's run a
presidential race before
i guess that's maybe true when you
compare him to like
ted cruz ted cruz has run but he doesn't
have executive experience i guess that
sort of makes sense
but florida governor ron desantis
has executive experience for whatever
reason governorships are called
executive experience i guess it's
because they are more administrative in
a sense than for example being a member
of the house or a member of the u.s
senate
desantis as axios writes is experiencing
a surge of popularity from republicans
because he opened florida wide open very
early
but desantis has not yet been
scrutinized
by national media as a candidate and who
knows what might surface
from that axios writes that christie's
approach would be to run
on his reputation for being tough and
that that could appeal to the trump base
but he's not going to come off as
reckless the way donald trump
came off you know the entire uh
george washington bridge closing down a
lane as a political uh punishment
that seems pretty reckless to me but i
guess when you're comparing
the recklessness of christie to the
recklessness of trump
he seems less reckless that's true axia
axios also writes that chris christie
may have crossover appeal
to blue-collar voters as well as
suburban
center-right voters that's possible and
also that his experience as a former
federal prosecutor
could distinguish him in debates and
prepare him for a primary
where um there may be more of a premium
placed on
sort of being buttoned up rather than
being unhinged like donald trump
i think that this is tough for chris
christie you know the the things that
he's known for
really in my mind are
um the the bridgegate fiasco
and supporting donald trump in
completely humiliating
fashion in 2016. and
neither of those are particularly
inspiring from my perspective
but listen maybe the republican primary
uh voters would would like
it christy didn't do well in 2016. i
don't know that he ever had more than
like two or three percent support but
listen things are different
and i think what is abundantly clear is
that christy is only a candidate
if trump does not run and uh
again we'll dig into that in more detail
on friday
who might actually run against trump
because christie's only a candidate if
trump is not
ted cruz isn't going to run against
donald trump lindsey graham
forget about it lindsey graham i don't
think is running regardless but lindsey
graham is not going to run against
donald trump
nikki haley told us last week or was it
monday
that she if donald trump runs she won't
run
and she will support donald trump so uh
that
that is the the situation with uh chris
christie
i actually what's crazy is
if you said to me whoever wins the
republican primary
will be the president chris christie is
maybe the guy i lean towards i mean if
you say
chris christie or ted cruz will be the
next president i'm going with chris
christie
if you say chris christie or i don't
even know you know
rand paul will be the next president i'm
going with chris christie uh
he has i'm not praising him but
he has more centrist sensibilities
he actually seems competent
in a narrow way that donald trump is not
when you think about his experience as a
prosecutor and as a governor he did
horrible things as a governor
bridgegate is an immoral fiasco
but i probably lean towards someone like
chris christie
more than just about anybody i can think
of that ran
in i mean kasich and again i'm not
saying these people are my ideal
candidates it's just if i knew that the
republican nominee would be the
president i'm leading towards someone
like maybe kasich or chris christie
despite having many many disagreements
with them so
let me know what you think about chris
christie's potential candidacy
we'll talk friday about who might
actually fight trump in the 2024
republican primary if it were to come to
that